why are you doing this because of school
i am it's what i do
well friends it's time to move over and
make room for your dark passenger once
again because dexter
is officially coming back and here's
everything we know about it right now on
the ketchup
after seven years off the air showtime
has ordered a new 10-episode revival of
its hit show about a blood splatter
analyst who moonlights as a serial
killer
it ran for eight seasons starting back
in 2006 with six of them coming in fresh
on the tomato meter michael c hall who
received five straight emmy knobs and
one golden globe and sag awards for
playing dexter will be returning to the
role
along with the original showrunner clyde
phillips who left after the first four
seasons to spend more time with family
family first and while this news might
come as a bit of a shock to many the
idea has actually been kicked around
hollywood a lot over the years
especially because of how the show ended
and yes that means we are about to talk
spoilers
in what critics have called a bitterly
disappointing final season we last saw
dexter sending his girlfriend hannah
and his son harrison to live in
argentina while he faked his own death
and began living a solitary life as a
lumberjack in oregon
trust me it is just as frustrating the
second time you watch it
stay away from me showtime's
co-president of entertainment gary
levine said in a statement that
quote we would only revisit this unique
character if we could find a creative
take that was
truly worthy of the brilliant original
series and well i am happy to report
that clyde phillips and michael c hall
have found it and we can't wait to shoot
it and show it to the world
we can't wait either this new set of
episodes will be a continuation of the
previous eight seasons
and we'll recognize the time that has
passed but phillips told the hollywood
reporter's top five podcast that we want
this
not to be dexter season nine this will
have no resemblance to how the original
finale was and it's a great opportunity
to write a second finale for a show
phillips has reportedly already written
the first and last episodes for the new
season but it's interesting to note that
he actually told e
online back in 2013 how he would have
ended the show
had he not left halfway through its run
and that's with dexter about to be
executed looking out at a gallery filled
with all the people that he's killed
over the years
i mean at this point anything sounds
better than what we got
but while the new ending will remain a
mystery until the fall of 2021 at the
earliest we do know that after eight
seasons taking place in miami there are
plenty of new places the show could go
geographically speaking of course we
could see dexter teaming back up with
his dark passenger while living his
lumberjack life in oregon
or maybe head to argentina to train his
son in the ways of the code
he could even head back to miami to join
up with the fan favorite detective
batista played by david zeus
i don't know but the suspense has me on
a table wrapped in plastic and it's
maybe you should come with me all right
friends it's time for us to kick it over
to you now what are your thoughts on
this dexter revival sound off in the
comments section
and be sure to check out
rottentomatoes.com if you want more
movie and streaming news
and don't forget to also check out our
brand new podcast rotten tomatoes is
wrong a podcast from rotten tomatoes
because fresh orion is just the
beginning of the conversation and new
episodes drop every thursday
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit the subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup
my name's nas perez and we'll see you in
the next video bye
you